like many of you we are following the
guidelines to stay home as much as
possible Anthony's in his library I'm in
the family room and Tony's in his
basement but this is where we begin
despite the relentless rise in
coronavirus cases and deaths more states
are beginning to reopen as of today at
least 12 states have started relaxing
restrictions to allow some businesses to
open their doors in a limited way they
say that includes Georgia where the
decision has faced widespread criticism
including from President Trump Anthony
California has not loosened the rules
gale but thousands still packed beaches
in Orange and Ventura counties which
were open over the weekend locals say
the large crowds resembled those seen on
the 4th of July California has the fifth
most confirmed cases in the country the
danger is still very real in just the
past four weeks the death toll in the US
has jumped from about 2500 to about
55,000 that includes an increase of
about 14,000 since this time last week
dr. Vivek Murthy fought Ebola and Zika
as the 19th Surgeon General during the
Obama administration and now he's
talking to presidential candidate Joe
Biden and local leaders about how to
tackle the corona virus he also wrote
the new book together the healing power
of human connection in a sometimes
lonely world
moorthi believes togetherness can help
solve many of our problems and dr.
Murthy joins us now from Miami dr.
Murthy good morning what a timely book
but speaking of timely your expertise as
a public health expert also very timely
so I want to begin there you've been
advising state and local governments on
this question of when to reopen what are
you telling them well it's so nice to be
with you this morning you know what I'm
telling people whether their elected
officials or reporters or anyone who
will listen is that it is important for
us to reopen as quickly as possible but
to do so safely and that means at this
point first and foremost that we have to
have much more expanded and available
testing we then have to follow that up
with the contact tracing that can help
essentially drop a net over new cases
when we find that
and if we have these in place along with
the search capacity we need in hospitals
that when fake cases finally start to
dip down then we can safely start to
reopen with cautions we will still need
to keep distance from each other we'll
still need to ensure that we're wearing
masks in public but we leak police have
a fighting chance at preventing a second
surge with those guidelines in mind how
do governors and mayors balance the
known health effects of unemployment and
loneliness with the known health effects
of the virus and is pandemic yes so this
is a this is an unprecedented situation
that we're in and and I appreciate that
there are really tough choices to make
here but one thing we have to avoid is
the false choice between people's health
and the economy if we really want to get
the economy back up and running if you
want people to to not lose any more than
they've already lost we've got to make
sure that we are taking care of people's
health and that we're making it safe if
we don't do that if we open prematurely
then what happens is we will have
another surge and everyone will have to
retreat back in to stay at home measures
which will actually hit the economy even
harder later on but as much as you know
people talk about the economic impact
which is serious and the direct health
impact which is real there's another
impact that we haven't talked about as
much and that's the impact on our social
lives as I wouldn't worry about it it's
the social recession that we may incur
as a result of the prolonged physical
distancing and fear of the virus that
may deepen our loneliness over time and
that has real consequences for our
health as well you know one way to
mitigate that social recession as you
call it is to ramp up testing dr.
Anthony Fauci of the coronavirus task
force says we need to double testing any
things we'll be able to do it in the
weeks ahead diagnostic testing that is
what would that testing system look like
how would we experience it as everyday
Americans what it would look like is our
ability to number one and get tests to
whoever needs them so particularly
people who are at higher risk health
care workers the elderly in nursing
homes frontline workers who are working
in grocery stores and in other jobs
where they're in constant contact with
people they need to be able to be tested
whenever whenever they require
and second we know it would also look
like doctors being able to get tests for
anybody who has symptoms that is still
tough for many physicians now and
finally it would look like rapid
turnaround of tests right now there are
still clinicians who are having to wait
three four or five days to get test
results we need to shorten that to the
rapid point of care test which can
deliver results within minutes dr.
Martha you've got a book out right now
or actually tomorrow called togetherness
at a moment when togetherness is the one
thing public health experts like
yourself say we can't engage in so
loneliness is a problem how do we combat
it at a moment when we can't reach out
and touch someone well this is one of
the great conundrums of today and if you
had told me a year ago when I was
writing this book on loneliness and
social connection a book that was
inspired really by the conversations I
had with people around the country when
our Surgeon General that showed me that
in fact loneliness is far more common
and as far more impacts on our health
and we think you know I would have
thought that gosh you know that we would
never be in the current situation that
we're in where were asked to physically
distance from each other but here's the
truth we can choose one of two paths
that we go down now we can either allow
the current physical distancing to
deepen our separation from each other
and increase our loneliness which in
turn has long-term impacts on our
increased risk for heart disease
dementia depression and anxiety or we
can go in the opposite direction and say
that we are gonna use this moment to
reset our lives to recommit to making
relationships a priority in our lives
and there are some simple steps that we
can take to do that right now even
though we don't have the ability to see
each other in person and that's what I
really go through and it was it was an
instant I was inspired to do it really
by by folks who taught me that as a
doctor you know we we see lots of
illnesses like diabetes and hypertension
doctor more thing but this is one that
we have not been paying enough attention
to I think that's right dr. Morton I was
gonna mention to those tips in the book
one of them being take time every day 15
minutes to connect with the people most
important you in your life and second
when you do that make sure you focus
don't have another thing going on don't
be cooking at the same time just
one-on-one connection so important as
we're
mind ER right now dr. Vivek Murthy thank
you very much and your book togetherness
it goes on sale tomorrow and you can
hear more from dr. Murthy about the
fight against loneliness on today's CBS
this morning podcast it's available
wherever you like to get your podcasts